we were asked to help a global bank
customer that had spent two years
developing an application meant to be
used by their tellers across their bank
branches the thousands of business users
across hundreds of branches worldwide
were seeing performance problems
when the customer has a problem even
though it's in code that they wrote
that's still on top of our product so we
certainly jump in and help there were a
lot of issues and they escalated to our
team the SWAT team to come in and give
an assist the digital business
automation SWAT team is a little like a
real SWAT team we're a quick response
reactive team that brings deep technical
skills across all of our products to
solve the customers issue as quickly as
possible any customer that's
experiencing a difficult issue has
access to the SWAT team what we're
looking for is to really dig down into
the problem and get real hands on
information to see where we can help and
what we can do to best help the customer
you start when the customer starts and
you know you don't finish until the
customer is done for the day so you know
it might be a 12 hour 16 hour day
whatever it takes a problem like this
it's important to look at the entirety
of the application we want to look at
the hardware it's running on we want to
look at the operating system they're
using the database and how they've
developed their UI and it was important
for our team to come in and we were able
to get them down to five seconds one of
the great things about working in IBM
support is every customer situation
brings a new problem and I know based on
our experience that we're gonna solve
that problem and we're gonna get the
customer to where they want to be
[Music]